Ukrainian military official
saying soldiers, in fact, mood
have been shelled by Russian
more than 400 times in
just the past 24 hours.
And just look at this.
I'm shown here
this is new footage
that we just have aerial footage
of what used to be back moved.
It is just
completely charred out, burned out
destroyed shell of a city.
And this comes as the Ukrainian sniper
that we've interviewed
several times on OUTFRONT
you may remember him
Roman truck and that's
he is sharing with us
some dramatic video
from the trenches around parking lot
that he has just filmed.
I'm going to show it to you.
I want to warn you
that what you're about to see is graphic.
But he did
want us to go ahead and share it.
It's a Ukrainian soldier
that has been severely wounded
by an explosion
receiving lifesaving medical treatment
from other soldiers.
Ultimately, this soldier did survive.
As I mentioned, though, it's
difficult to watch,
but he thought it was
important to share with you
good with you.
Well, you know, we should have known
how do you get to have physical
and what is right.
And there's no Michael
Sam tying the tourniquet.
And as we said, that soldier did survive.
Nick Paton Walsh is OUTFRONT
with our coverage now
on the frontlines in southern Ukraine.
Occupied
Ukraine is aflame
and evacuating its civilians.
Russia's wholesale departure
can't come soon enough.
The front line town not a heave.
This premium ravaged by Moscow
where four missiles
hit on Thursday alone.
Rescue was left guessing
what the constant bangs
mean and have done.
See people just down the road here.
Carrying on life
as per normal, despite
dust in the sky around us at night.
Just gets emotional between us.
You know what we do
and may not be, in fact,
that emotional shortcoming.
Also, the
I think
that you feel personally near
to through the energy to evaporate.
Give me a lot of gratitude for you
saying it doesn't mean particularly
a time of day
when these sort of things start
could be any time at all frankly
but as dusk
falls, the sky is lit in a duel.
All they can do here to stay
alive is read the horizon
some of it perhaps further
south into occupied areas
than a week earlier.
But so much of it
also very close
Dawn is often jarring.
We hear a jet overhead,
the slowly building grating
sound of damage, moving towards
a missile, a half million dollar catch.
31 Ukrainian officials later say lands
just 700 yards away
Several times
I was on the floor very but.
Another blast follows
either jet entrails
or anti-aircraft fire.
Settle to shape a Z in the air.
The symbol of Russia's invasion.
It is soon gone.
The damage it leaves, though isn't.
This is where it hit or missed.
Down here,
you can get a feeling of
just how massively
brutal Russian firepower can be
and also how indiscriminate.
I can still smell
the explosive down here.
And you're kind of left wondering
where the obvious military target is.
At the end of this road is Pelosi.
One of the towns
Russia has said it is evacuating
We are just one mile
from Russian frontline positions here,
a world torn apart
as Moscow tries to hold Ukraine back.
Well,
no more than ten miles in that direction
are the first towns
that Russian occupying forces
say they're going to be evacuating
because
of the Ukrainian counter-offensive.
Look here.
The last town
really held by Ukraine,
absolutely battered
and so few people left here
has little need to evacuate
where there were once 3000.
There are 200 people trying to stay,
says Rice.
When we used, we had to land each in.
What did you get?
There was a line was,
I should warn you, that was
caught in these wide open spaces
where a distant bank
can suddenly alter life in an instant.
Aaron, Russian officials
say they've now
evacuated 3000
individual civilians,
mostly from the areas
along the front line,
potentially
where Ukraine may launch
its counter
offensive Ukrainian
officials say that's
impacting cash withdrawals,
gasoline availability and also cell phone
service, too.
And even that one particular town
scattered to
the west of Crimea
may have seen a lot of people
leaving it recently.
Most importantly, though,
many Ukrainians here,
I think, are bracing themselves
for a night
of maybe more missile strikes,
drone strikes as well.
A lot of them being intercepted
by air defense over the past night.
But tomorrow
for Russia,
particularly important it's victory day.
The 9th of May
be celebrated in Moscow itself.
And we sadly know that Moscow
tend to mark anniversaries here
in Ukraine
with a bid to create more bloodshed Erin.
Thank you very much, Nick Frum's.
Appreciate tonight.
I want to go straight now
to the retired Army Lieutenant
General Mark Hertling.
And General
Hertling, part of your next,
talking about Russia evacuating
3000 people from the front lines in Japan
region near where Nick is tonight
due to increased shelling.
They've got lines of busses
we're showing them.
They're using those to transport
people away.
Now, as operation, of course, has been
seen as a major target
likely in the coming
Ukrainian counter offensive.
So what do you
think Russia is doing here?
Well,
Erin, first of all, is up where is it
as an entire oblast?
So you're talking about
several hundred square kilometers.
The make no mistake,
Russia is not evacuating these people
for humanitarian reasons.
They haven't done that anywhere else.
What they're doing
is taking people, citizens away
so that they don't help the incoming
Ukrainian forces.
That are coming in.
You know, it's the same thing
the Nazis did in France
where they
killed the resistance fighters.
They moved fighters away
so that they couldn't help their allies
when they were coming into France
and then later into Germany.
So that's what they're doing.
They're getting rid of the population
so they can't help and spot
where Russians are.
They can't
tell the Ukrainian forces
where the defensive positions are.
They can't point out sniper positions.
So those are
the kind of things
that are going on right now.
Well,
I think it's important to be
clear, right?
There is nothing humanitarian about it
as you lay out.
Now, another thing
I want to ask you about,
because you have Jennifer
Goshen, the head of the volunteer
group, is now saying
his troops are getting ammunition
and that they're advancing, in fact.
The reason I'm mentioning this
is that, you know,
you and I remember talking just days ago,
he was warning
he was going to pull all of his troops
out of back
this week
because they were losing
and they couldn't win
and they had no ammunition
and no support,
nothing from the Russian military.
Now, all of a sudden, they're advancing
and they've got the ammo what
do you read into that?
I read
into it that it
is more Russian and Kremlin drama.
It is political back
and forth
between going from
the leader of the Chechen fighters,
Shoigu, the defense minister,
and Gerasimov,
the leader of the Russian military,
all centered around.
You know, the interesting thing is this
has been dysfunctional now
for almost 18 months. Yes.
These kind of analogies
have been at play.
And even on the on
the eve of a grand
offensive by the Ukrainian forces,
they're still screwing around,
trying to figure out who's in charge.
And the leader is
none of this is military activity
the way professional soldiers see it.
All right.
Thank you very much, General, as always.
Thank you.